there was a proper fighting going on
the enemy was using all
its weapons
infrastructure
ukrainian people deserve
and defense military
help is coming to ukraine and work is
going on on
disconnecting russia from sweden
hungary
um
to destroy
[Music]
if you can destroy the occupiers please
do it everyone who can come back to
ukraine please come back to defend
ukraine and after that
we will have a lot of work to do to
rebuild
very shortly how this can be done
the bridge
and lost his wife is now announced hero
of ukraine
and now
i want everyone in russia to hear me
everybody
soldiers who
are here in ukraine don't know why they
were sent here to kill people or to be
killed the sooner you tell your
government that the war has to be
stopped
more people from your country will stay
alive
your nationals are voicing
their opposition to this war we know
that many people in russia are shocked
now
by the brutality of the russian
government and this is the right's
reaction i'm grateful to this reaction
and thousands of
decent russian people whose conscience
is voicing their opinion
please stop those who are lying who are
trying to lie to you who is lying to us
we need to stop this war
we can live in peace together
nationals of ukraine
please carry on
we will win
glory to ukraine